[Música]
y precisamente con el primer invitado
hablaremos de los cambios que ha habido
en la guerra en ucrania ahora la
discusión se centra en si rusia tiene o
no equipos militares dentro de la planta
nuclear de sap orilla y que tanto riesgo
implica esto ante un posible desastre
atómico hoy el presidente ruso vladimir
putin dijo que su ejército no tiene
equipamiento militar allí y su canciller
sérguei lávrov afirmó que le pediría
explicaciones al respecto al oiea
precisamente porque este organismo
atómico de la onu afirmó en su reporte
del 6 de septiembre que el equipo de
inspección si observó directamente
equipos militares rusos en las salas de
turbinas y en otros lugares alrededor de
la planta que tan relevante es esto para
la guerra y también qué está pasando con
la contraofensiva de ucrania en el sur y
para analizar el tema nos acompaña desde
argentina andrés servín pont director de
la coordinadora regional de
investigaciones económicas y sociales
bienvenido a france 24 un placer tenerlo
con nosotros empecemos hablando y
explicándole a nuestra audiencia cuáles
son los riesgos de tener equipos
militares dentro de una planta nuclear y
porque este debate
hola bueno muchas gracias por la
invitación un placer de participar
ha habido controversias desde el
principio del conflicto en torno a el
empleo de todo tipo de armamento cerca
de la planta nuclear recordemos que no
es el primer incidente que pone a esta
planta nuclear en el centro de atención
mundial esta infección lo que nos
permitió es observar claramente hay
evidencia fotográfica que ha sido
compartida por aquellos que realizaron
inspección de que existe material
militar presente y el riesgo ahí que
justamente ucrania a medida que trata de
avanzar sobre las instalaciones
militares necesitando poder neutralizar
los equipos militares rusos tenga que
emplear municiones de forma
peligrosamente cercana a los reactores
aunque cabe destacar de que muchos de
los expertos
en materia nuclear dicen que no es tan
fácil es simplemente un par de impactos
sobre un reactor nuclear como para
causar una catástrofe lo que no quita y
que no hayan riesgos y de que sobre todo
cuando sus armamento pesado pueda
ocurrir algún incidente grave bueno y
que esperemos que no ocurra este
incidente otra de las partes de este
reporte del oiea es que sugiere que los
rusos deben abandonar la planta nuclear
de esa polilla precisamente para evitar
estos riesgos y que los ucranianos se
comprometan a no tomarla para que los
rusos no estén incentivados a regresar
pero en el plano práctico qué tan
probable es que ambos ejércitos acepten
estos
a ver ahí es cuando tenemos una
desconexión entre las instancias
políticas y las instancias tácticas
ninguno de los ejércitos va estar
dispuesto a
no ocupar un territorio que consideran
particular importancia tantos niveles
operacionales como estratégicos por ende
es una realidad que no se condice con la
realidad del terreno un conflicto armado
convencional entre pares de esa manera
es poco probable que alguna de las
partes esté dispuesta a negociar algo
como esto dado de que simplemente es el
punto de vista militar acceder a este
terreno sea un lado del otro no es
viable y que está pasando precisamente
en sap orilla que tan controlada está
por los rusos actualmente teniendo en
cuenta que allí está la central nuclear
bueno hemos visto la presencia que está
en este momento
ahí se ha hablado en múltiples ocasiones
sobre cómo podrían avanzar eventualmente
las fuerzas ucranianas en semanas
pasadas tuvimos intercambios muy fuertes
capaz en las próximas semanas esto
cambió un poco sobre todo a partir de
las noticias de hoy no estamos viendo
una nueva contraofensiva que estaba más
bien en la región de kharkiv
apuntando hacia el este y el sudeste y
lo que está haciendo ucrania que
justamente busca explotar aprovechar
ciertos vacíos o líneas un poco más
débiles del lado ruso sobre todo
aquellas que no puedan reforzar así que
a medida de que avance esa
contraofensiva es probable que hagamos
una disminución de los enfrentamientos
cerca de la planta bueno y profundicemos
ahora sobre un tema que usted menciona y
es la contraofensiva ucraniana más al
oeste de sap orilla concretamente en
here son los ucranianos se están
concentrando para atacar las fuerzas
rusas y recordemos que gerson fue la
primera gran ciudad ucraniana que cayó
en poder de moscú durante la guerra que
está pasando allí y por qué es la
importancia geopolítica en materia
militar también de ejercer
a ver la contraofensiva en casa se ha
visto bien avanzando a un ritmo quizás
un poco más lento de que se esperaban
por lo menos las analistas occidentales
rusia ha logrado desplegar una gran
cantidad de medios tiene fuerzas de
reservas para poder lidiar con algún
tipo de contraofensiva y sobre todo si
llegan a penetrar sus líneas a parte de
los rusos tienen una situación
complicada en el punto de vista táctico
es que tienen un río a sus espaldas no
entonces de manera de que un repliegue
audio sumamente dificultoso necesitan
asegurarse resistir este terreno pero
por otro lado ha servido justamente para
esta otra contraofensiva que estaba
mencionando que está ocurriendo en las
últimas horas en la región de kharkiv
justamente a los rusos al haber
reforzado la relación de ejercer la
región de gerzón no han podido desplegar
mayores reservas en la región de jarquín
lo que ha facilitado que el ejército
ucraniano logra avanzar sobre esa región
con bastante éxito según los indicios de
las primeras horas en la ofensiva
esperar ver como realmente se va
consolidando esa contraofensiva si es
que esto ocurre bueno vemos entonces un
reacomodamiento de las fuerzas en gerson
y en kharkiv en el que los ucranianos
están presionando que tanto ha
contribuido a esta contraofensiva los
implementos militares que han dado la
unión europea reino unido y eeuu sobre
todo le preguntó por los cohetes y mars
efectivamente han sido clave no pensemos
de que ucrania tiene que lidiar no sólo
con la necesidad de nuevas tecnologías
para poder lidiar con las capacidades
militares rusas sino que a la vez su
sobre dependencia histórica sobre
sistemas de armas y municiones de
procedencia soviética significa que hoy
no tiene una línea logística para
sostener todos esos sistemas de armas
por lo cual poco a poco no sólo está
comprando tecnología de punta
adquiriendo tecnología de punta oa
través de donaciones también occidental
sino que tecnologías un poquito más
desfasados antiguas también están
reemplazando los viejos sistemas
soviéticos así que la logística
ucraniana se está reconvirtiendo gracias
a los esfuerzos los países occidentales
que le dan este apoyo si el sistema de
armas y mars lo que permite es poder
atacar puntos de valor ya operacional
como son los grandes depósitos de
munición rusos y así reducir
drásticamente las capacidades ofensivas
rusas y muy rápidamente quiero
preguntarle a qué se debe el cambio de
narrativas tanto de rusia como de
ucrania que han bajado un poco sus
expectativas en la palabra
creo que por lo menos en las últimas
semanas se volvió cada vez más evidente
la posibilidad de que este del que el
frente se vuelva cada vez más estático y
a medida que se vuelva más estático una
guerra sobre todo de
posiciones atrincheradas intercambio de
artillería se empieza a definir una
línea que se mueva con mucho menos
flexibilidad lo que vimos en los últimos
meses y por en algún momento se generen
las condiciones para que ambas partes se
sienten a negociar ahora vamos a ver
cómo continúa esto si la contraofensiva
ucraniana en jarquín es exitoso y sobre
todo si logran continuar con la
contraofensiva en carson lo cual
obviamente cambiaría un poco el
paradigma de los rusos en cuanto cómo
ves perciben que avanza el conflicto
armado